let me actually let's let's pull the
story up and dive into it from nbc news
pentagon says supreme court's row ruling
won't affect abortions on military
facilities right the military will
continue providing abortions in cases of
rape or incest or when the mother's life
is at risk a top pentagon official said
okay
texas does not allow those exceptions
rape and incest only the health of the
mother right the life of the mother
so my question is
let's say you you have a civilian doctor
and a
female army
you know personnel yeah
they she lives off base she's married
civilian doctor does not live on base
but he contracts the hospital on base or
not even that he doesn't need to be
silly let's say he's uh he's active duty
military as well lives off base they
both under the jurisdiction living under
the jurisdiction of texas are subject to
its laws and rules
if you are in the army and you break the
law you face military court and civilian
court you get trouble two times so we
know
they have to obey the laws obviously you
can't have a person to be like i'm in
the military so i can do what i want
so they go into the military base she
gets an abortion the doctor performs it
there is now a record of that having
occurred and the u.s government has said
you cannot be criminally charged or
penalized civilly
for
having this procedure regardless of the
state law right but some of these states
have actually uh i don't know if they've
passed them yet they say if you aid and
abet an abortion you're guilty of a
crime so that means
the doctor and the woman regardless of
where it's performed coming back into
that state could be arrested because
they have committed the crime according
to that state right what happens if the
state then says we don't care what the
fed said and they arrest
this contractor or to active duty
military and the military is like you
can't arrest them it's not illegal and
say it is here yeah what happens when
states start arresting military
personnel well i think there are three
things there one is the what happens
when the states start arresting them the
second part is is a
law that says you can't do something
effectively somewhere else somewhere
outside of our jurisdiction is that
going to be able to hold up in court and
then also the question of specific to
this uh what if the feds just stop
recording it what if the fed's just it's
you know no questions asked uh
abortion's being performed and they just
don't you know i got one more for you
okay woman's in the military
she is married
pregnant
the man says i really think we should
have this kid and she says i don't yeah
and he says i
refuse to allow the abortion happen i
think it's wrong i think it's murder
and she says too bad
he knows where she goes he knows who
does it and he reports it to the local
state but to the state police
you know maybe they're not married
because i don't know if a husband would
do that but let's say there's like oh
she hooks up with the guy yeah whatever
yeah and the guy's just like i refuse to
allow you to get an abortion i reject
this so he reports her doesn't matter if
the feds are tracking it or not if you
know that you have a witness come out
and then the feds take the active duty
person and say we're going to
interrogate you for part of our
investigation and she says yes i did it
and it was illegal it was on federal
jurisdiction they'd say
okay stand up hands behind your back
you're under arrest your rights remain
silent she's like what house is
happening and they say the law states if
you ate and abetted abortion and go
somewhere it doesn't matter where it
took place i don't know if texas has
that ruling but
the general idea i suppose is
it's not necessarily the same thing as i
think it might have been like iowa idaho
where they said if you aid in a bet
but if this military base is in texas
the feds might be like it happened on
federal jurisdiction texas might still
say you're still in texas you still live
under our laws
and regardless of that let's just say
letter of the law no no no they can't do
that right okay well according to james
buchanan states weren't legally allowed
to succeed either didn't stop him right
so what happens if you get
a christian conservative prosecutor in
texas who says we have made it illegal
to kill babies
and then you went into a military base
and killed a baby i'm gonna i'm gonna
charge you and i'm gonna bring i'm gonna
take it all the way to the top because i
believe it's the right thing to do it
doesn't matter what the federal
government thinks they're protected on
and then what the feds are gonna be like
trying to pull their people out of the
jail filing lawsuits does it end in a
legal battle or does it end with
the state police surrounding federal law
enforcement vehicles at gunpoint and
saying you're under arrest what happens
then if a federal agent tries getting
the woman out even though she's a known
fugitive of state law is it possible
texas then says you've added and abetted
a fugitive i don't care if you're doing
it the feds have no authority to super
to to undermine our laws think about it
this way
let's say a federal agent
let's say a female member of the army
murders a kid hits him with a car
and it was on duty driving a military
vehicle and the kid dies and the state
says you are driving recklessly we have
a witness you're under arrest and then
the military says no she was on she was
active duty it was an accident we reject
those charges what happens
oh there i mean that's obvious right
like if it's if it's on you know in the
jurisdiction of the state where this
gets mucky would be if she did it on a
military base and the military said
we're handling it and the state said no
it's in our jurisdiction my
understanding of that is that that
wouldn't be their jurisdiction all right
let's try this but we could also talk
about there could be a prosecutor who
says you know reality of power
stop me right the court said i can't do
it the supreme court said i can't do it
i'm doing it anyway come and stop me
here oh so so just throwing
hypotheticals out there i'm not saying
anything any of these are like highly
probable uh pizza delivery guy he go he
drives on a base and they're like what
are you here for and he's like i gotta
deliver a pizza to base housing and
they're like all right we're gonna start
your vehicle and then you're cool and
then he's driving in and then while on
duty as an mp she crashes into him flips
him over killing him and she was she was
not paying attention and she made an
illegal lane change and the military
says we're not prosecuting this we think
it was an accident and then the family
of the of the driver says he's a
civilian who's in our state we reject
this we want them charged yeah yeah i i
think it's highly likely in most
circumstances in that case they'd be
like it happened on the military base
the feds are gonna have to have yeah i
was gonna say i believe that that's
there's already some long-standing
precedent um both uh i'm not even sure
if i had to be judicial i think that's
understanding that on military base that
is federal land that's not that's not
state jurisdiction so where the question
arises then where this starts to become
more akin to the civil war is
women
going to federal military going to
military bases when they're not active
duty to get abortions
the state knows they're doing it does
the state say to the federal government
stop breaking our laws or else and the
feds say it's our military base you
can't do anything about it and they say
we will send in state police to arrest
these women the moment they step foot
out they're getting arrested because you
are like
if people start going on a military
basis they say and again i know this is
a bit of a stretch
they're going to be providing abortions
i think it's typically only done for
military personnel on military bases but
there are people on the left arguing for
effectively making them sanctuaries
right exactly
so my suggestion is
is this direction the direction we may
be going oh very much
i mean you want to talk about a culture
war uh there is a gap between those who
see this as you know a woman exerting uh
autonomy over her body against a clump
of cells a parasite and other people are
saying no this is a murder of a baby
every bit as much as if if the woman
were to turn around and murder someone
standing next to him and and there's
it's hard to have a compromise between
that right and so if this plays out and
and both sides are willing to go to the
trenches over it this could lead to what
we're talking about or even worse on
just even this specific subject you made
a good point reality of power that they
can say whatever they want it doesn't
matter and who's willing to do something
about it and so i suppose the issue is
let's take the moral issue of today with
you with abortion and and go back in
time to slavery
so let's say in the north they said
we've abolished slavery
and then let's say it's let's say it's
in uh pennsylvania
and so it's right on the border of
maryland which was a slave state and
then you have a military base there that
has slaves and they're like we don't
care that you abolished this we're
keeping we're just going to do it anyway
john brown
would uh probably lose it over that
right the abolitionist would be like
don't know don't care yeah you can't do
this it's wrong
so that that what i fear is
it's just crazy to me that texas would
come out so strong
no exceptions for rape or incest and the
military says we will
like we're getting to that point where
you just need to imagine it this way
if abortion is murder at least in the
eyes of the christian conservatives
what they're basically saying is we will
keep killing children and you can't stop
us right yeah at a certain point law
enforcement's going to be like we have
codified this in our law that you cannot
do this and you are doing it yeah well
it's not murder i don't care what what
people believe it's not murder
let's keep that in mind why is it not
murder it's not illegal in texas it is
well in certain places if you do it in
the wrong spot you might consider it a
murderer i don't know if there is
are you saying from a legal standpoint
legal standpoint murder is a legal term
it's killing it's it's definitely a form
of homicide i mean it depends on if you
consider the lump of cells a human right
does are they legally is illegal in
texas it is the unlawful killing of a
person in texas is it it's literally is
it a person from inception did they
codify that all i know is that abortions
are illegal in texas yeah i don't i
don't think that i don't think they've
they've codified it as murder they've
just as a as a criminal action okay um
but i don't yeah because otherwise it
would be uh it wouldn't just be going
after providers it would be if you have
an abortion if you're a pregnant woman
that has an abortion you can face the
death penalty for example i mean that
that would be the level that would be
imagine if the pro-life movement took it
to the place where they were killing
mothers or for having abortions but but
you you know you talk to sheamus even
he's very pro-life he wants a national
ban and even he doesn't want to go there
right he's he views it more as the
doctors shouldn't be allowed to perform
these things he's not going to penalize
the mothers
who are you know in these positions or
whatever
what makes me
really bothers me is the idea that a
state would would prosecute someone for
something they did outside of the
jurisdiction i don't understand that
bothers me the most out of all of this
and i mean we could talk about my
concerns about uh how a war on abortion
is just as successful as the war on
drugs were on terror war on poverty
everything else what happens when you
get government involved as a regulatory
body on something like pregnancy uh and
the harm that comes from that but the
just inside of this the biggest thing
i'm concerned of on a broader scale is
the idea of oh you did that over there
yeah no don't ever come back or we'll
arrest you like that i mean take that to
its logical conclusion it doesn't sound
are there any other instances in the
united states i don't believe that would
be held up there may be some some rule
but as far as i can think i i can't
think of an instance where um going
because i mean you think you take that
to its logical conclusion it's not just
within the u.s that could mean someone
that goes to uh you know the the
netherlands and tries uh you know uh
ketamine or tries cannabis or something
and then comes back to a state where
it's illegal gets arrested because they
put it on social media that they did it
um and then you could even get more
obscure with things that like violate a
bylaw in your county but they they don't
violate a bylaw where you were i the the
enforcement mechanism there would be
horrific and yeah it needs to be if
there's going to be a semblance of rule
of law it's
the jurisdiction you are under those are
the rules that you are under not not the
crimes you committed and then come back
or the things you did there that were
perfectly fine and legal but then you
come back home or or wherever you reside
and now it's it's illegal there so now
you're going to be charged for a crime i
mean imagine hard enough to figure out
what's illegal in a given place where
you are to try to figure out what's
illegal any place you would then go
after that yeah i i can't see that being
held though then that would be a major
problem and like and like tim said we
don't even know if texas has that but
there are other states that have tried
implementing that for abortion and some
of these other things and its
politicians honestly virtue signaling to
their base not only can't they do it
here they can't do it anywhere well
that's probably not going to be held up
and would you want that to be held up
like would you want the government to
tell you what you can and can't do when
you aren't even in under their
jurisdiction i certainly wouldn't no no
not at all ian i know you said um
abortion is not
murder
uh from the legal standpoint of the word
but then what do you make of
uh
murdering a pregnant woman being
considered double homicide oh it's
homicide it's just not murder homicide
is the killing of a human um murder is
the illegal i don't know what's their
different definitions so like murder is
a form of homicide okay right i don't
know if those abortion bans are
considering abortion homicide though
they're not in louisiana i think they
tried to codify that and then it got
bumped right now no one wants to do that
yeah once i touch that yeah mary's point
was in um i think i think scott peterson
i think sheamus brought that up i don't
know if it's peterson yes yeah when he
got charged with double homicide because
he killed lacey peterson and their
unborn child
right so there are jurisdictions where
if a woman is pregnant you punch her in
the stomach you can get charged with
murder you know
actual murder yeah yeah yeah actual like
the the mother service or manslaughter
she miscarries yeah yeah okay well you
i'm just to clarify you can get charged
with murdering the baby if you punch her
in the gut right i murder manslaughter
it depends on i believe it's state by
state because i know in california and a
lot of people thought how ironic
california which is you know when it
comes to abortion the most uh uh you
know liberal on that subject uh but when
scott peterson killed lacey peterson and
her child
he was charged with double homicide with
double murder very strange for
california
they're like no no no he he did kill her
but the rest was a clump of cells it it
comes down to the argument that well it
all depends on the mother's intent
because she wanted to keep the unborn no
i didn't say it made sense
age of the will where your will
equates to the to the truth of the
matter yeah no if it comes down to if if
a state because really it comes down to
personhood right like if a state has
decided that personhood doesn't begin
until birth or some point after
conception and this uh fetus unborn
child whatever you want to call it uh
hasn't reached that point of personhood
yet well then that would mean whether it
was through an abortion or through
someone killing the the mother or
attacking the mother and the the fetus
unborn person dies you would have to it
would either always be
a homicide or or a crime or it would
always not be that because that thing
doesn't have personhood yeah i would
think
there it's a there's a value to the
intricacy of of killing an unborn fetus
that maybe isn't considered a person
that's that's different than just
destroying a cell block but also
maybe not as horrific as like a murder
charge yeah it's some kind of a crime
was committed but not necessarily murder
if you're if you're going the route of
saying that it doesn't have personhood
yet thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you